what's going on guys Greg Alva here
spider-man Home Coming trailer number
two you know we got to do but before I
do the deal
ghost hunter Diaries episode one the
pilot has been released this is a pilot
for a comedy series that I'm not
starting in but I have a supporting role
in it my friend Randy Aguilar shhhhh
yes she's one of people put together
she's one of the stars of it I watched
it yesterday sure to a couple people who
were around we actually all laughed at
it I was like alright let's see how this
turned out and turned out pretty funny
actually ghost hunter diaries go over
there there's a link of the description
box to go watch the episode please go
support it like I said I have a role in
this thing so go check it out poor sabor
and say that the real rejects ain't you
anyway let's go watch spider-man
homecoming
raela / trailer oh cool back to the
future so to become an Avenger I was in
love trials or any movie do me a favor
Pacific will see a friendly neighborhood
spider-man
ah just stay close to the ground me you
two to keep some anonymous letters oh
yeah you know how to catch a signal the
diction of powerful I start they don't
care of Maya
world-changing boys and we changed too
[Music]
now mr. Gator forget the flying off
today they're people who handle the
sweeping the weapons barrels 2:30
[Music]
oh cool
Ironman to the rescue where somebody
died I was just trying to be like Jean I
want to be better I'm gonna need you
back but I'm nothing without this suit
if you're nothing about this shoe then
you shouldn't have screwed up the world
edition I want you to understand I'll do
anything except my pants
I know you know I was talking about
never built a trickshot her body goggles
and a wedding book he gets the girl
and now you pull out this I just got to
do this online
I was pretty crazy that a fight on ice
out of place
don't do anything stupid
all right yeah it's pretty stupid repeat
I mean like the goggle looking
everything it's pretty intense that you
really have to think about it like the
planes crashing you started guided in
the air by pulling on it showed you a
lot I think but I don't think it spoils
the whole movie I could definitely see
people saying it's boy who told of a
battle they get spoiled the entire film
I like it showed a lot but I can't
honestly tell you how from beginning to
end this whole play out I really like
the show they give us a good amount of
new stuff I like the thing with Spider
Man suit at the beginning where he like
puts it on it's all kind of like baggy
and stuff and then he touches the center
of the suit
it's kind of that Back to the Future 2
moment Marty McFly puts on the jacket or
the shoes and then the suit at just his
size
I wish shirts that don't fit me wouldn't
expand and do that for me
one thing I liked about from seeing this
trailer is it looks like he he has a
hard time being a good spider-man
he's having a hard time doing a good job
at being spider-man which has always
been like a reoccurring theme from a lot
of things we know about spider-man but
this seems to really harken back like we
got a lot of Tony Stark in this trailer
this is like semi Iron Man for you know
Marvel's not doing an Ironman for movie
but they're making him like the main
supporting character and Marvel films
and Terry starts kind of getting on his
ass because he Key's keeps he seems like
he keeps messing up as spider-man
when Tony started saying couldn't should
be a friendly neighborhood spider-man
and then he like crashes into the pool
which is something you kind of don't
think spider-man would have a problem
doing with you and to swim wrong and
hitting the pool and then getting some
people the character Ned leads I think
is going to be my favorite character
he's obviously the one I'll be able to
relate the most with I feel like once
this movie is done and then we go oh
which character would I be I'm
definitely gonna say Ned lead-ins I'm
really drawn to that dynamic but this
being the second reboot of the
spider-man film franchise it's nice to
see that he has this buddy that he could
bounce off of and share his powers with
and talk about the world they were like
having actual best friend who knows his
secret identity I think it's a nice
touch to have in this film and I could
totally see myself being that way with
like a you know a Kristian harloff or
something I thought it was kind of funny
how they were
and after-school specials that was led
by Captain America but I thought like
Captain America at this point is a
fugitive I don't know if that's like a
public thing that he's a fugitive taught
it would be a public thing that he's a
fugitive but either way I thought it was
kind of funny how they're using a
Captain America PSA a PSA of a current
fugitive in America one of my concerns
is still the fact that the MCU does not
do a great job with their villains most
of the time and they got Michael Keaton
in here and the vultures designs look
really cool and everything the trailer
you know it's like you can't focus on
everything on it a two minute trailer I
still haven't been given enough to go
like Michael Keaton looks like he's
really gonna rock in this role they're
gonna give a good amount of screen time
or the writing I don't really get a good
sense of who the vulture is and how he's
going to be in this film yeah he's a bad
guy Michael Keaton's playing him like a
bad guy from the little bits of footage
we got and Michael Caine seems like he's
going to be doing a good job regardless
I just feel like man you got Michael
Keaton here you guys need to make sure
that this this villain needs to be great
I like I really want it to be a great
villain because it's [ __ ] Michael
Keaton and I'll say they got shocker in
this trailer so they're putting in two
villains vultures the one who's really
being focused on here not really fire
myself drawn a vulture even though they
gave them a little more focus in the
trailer I'm still not feeling myself too
drawn to vulture other than the fact
that it's Michael Keaton and then you
know they share shockers in here too but
um I added we'd really have time for a
shocker in this movie so those are just
a couple of my concerns I can honestly
see people getting a little bit annoyed
that Tony Stark's in his trailer an
awful lot but I like the touch that he
has here you know he was in Captain
America Civil War he's the main
supporting character I thought that was
one of the best Iron Man performances
Robert Downey jr. has given I don't
think this will top it in terms of
emotional depth but I kind of I like
that he's playing the mentor to Peter
Parker here I thought that moment played
out well just even in the trailer when
he tells him if you're nothing without
the suit then you shouldn't have it kind
of reminds me of like what Iron Man 3
sort of showed us a man despite what you
think about Iron Man 3 it did show us
that Tony Stark is plenty without the
Iron Man suit my opinion at least that's
how I felt at times was done after
seeing Civil War we know the
see you can handle a really awesome
spider-man now here we got it really get
to know Peter Parker and I feel like
this film's really going to focus well
on that I feel like we're going to hone
in on really getting to see what makes
Peter Parker special we know what makes
spider-man special because we happy we
have to have a movie especially the
first installment where we love Peter
not just spider-man but Peter Parker and
kind of looking back at the trailer it
somewhat feels like it showed a lot
spider-man's doing his spiky thing Tony
keeps warning him about you know you got
to dial it back then vulture a taxi and
then he goes after vulture that whole
boat and ship thing happens and then
Tony takes away his suit that he goes
after vulture again I think that's why
it has like his older uniform with the
Spidey goggles he's going after vulture
so he has to prove that he can still be
you know a good Peter Parker spider-man
even without this suit that Tony gave
him and then maybe Iron Man comes in and
saves the day and takes out vulture with
the way how much Iron Man is helping out
in this trailer despite like whatever
criticisms I gave I don't just read it
on a hat me worried that this film is
going to be bad by any means I think
it's going to be a really fun film I
think the chemistry between Tom Hall and
Robert Downey jr. is great I think Tom
Horn is a really good spider-man visual
effects and the action sequences look
really cool the updated spider-man stuff
is really neat you know I even like that
moment where he shoots the web at the
one guy it hits him and like nothing
happens and suddenly he just flies and
watches to the wall
there's a lot of great stuff in this
trailer I'm excited for this movie I'll
definitely be there opening night
probably wearing this exact same t-shirt
that was the only spider-man shirt I
have subscribe to the reel rejects shout
out again to the ghost hunter Diaries
video that I was in you have to go watch
it please I told them that I would tell
you all to go watch it